monica rambo might have debuted in
captain marvel as an excitable kid
but in the comics she's a heroine in her
own right
in fact monica might be one of the most
powerful superheroes in the marvel
universe
this is her story monica made her debut
in 1982's amazing spider-man annual
number 16.
in this issue fans are introduced to the
spunky future avenger as lieutenant
rambo
an officer climbing the ranks of the new
orleans harbor patrol
while on a mission rambo takes a direct
shot of extra dimensional energy from a
criminal scientist's mysterious machine
as a result she is granted incredible
power over energy
monica is able to generate it manipulate
it absorb it and even
transform her body into pure energy
which enables her to travel at
astonishing speed through the vacuum of
space
after this incident monica encounters
some thieves who try to steal her purse
while chasing them down she accidentally
gets into a minor fight with spider-man
who's surprised at the amount of power
she's packing
but after the misunderstanding is
cleared up spidey along with an assist
from iron man
and the wasp helps her gain better
control over her volatile new found
powers
while monica was not the first marvel
character to debut in a spider-man comic
the issue marks the start of a strong
friendship between the lieutenant
and the wall crawler the two would team
up in many future comics
fans of the mcu might identify carol
danvers
brought to life on screen by oscar
winner brie larson
as the one and only captain marvel but
off-screen this couldn't be more
incorrect
within the pages of marvel comics the
captain marvel name has a long history
dating back to the 1960s
originating with the earthbound cree
warrior marvel
carol danvers is actually the seventh
character to take up the mantle and
she's certainly not the first woman to
do it
the first female hero to be known by the
name of captain marvel was actually none
other than monica rambo who was the
second person to take on the mantle
it's the media who originally dubs
monica captain marvel
astonished by her energy-based abilities
but curiously
her take on the name has nothing to do
with marvel or the cree
make sense perfectly not confusing
you can draw a straight line from carol
danvers's powers to the original marvel
but monica's powers and origin story
come from a completely different source
meaning that in marvel comics canon the
fact that they shared a name is
actually just a giant confusing
coincidence although she goes on to
change her hero names several times
throughout the years monica will always
be remembered as the first woman to kick
butt
as captain marvel monica rambo has made
many lasting marks on the history of the
marvel universe
when the avengers made her a
full-fledged member in 1983's avengers
number 231 monica officially became the
first african-american woman to join the
team's ranks
although she was then still pretty new
to the superhero life
both wasp the team's leader at the time
and captain america
her second in command admired monica's
powerful abilities and iron-clad
composure
monica wasn't the first african-american
heroine to join a marvel super team
that honor goes to aurora monroe better
known as the weather manipulating mutant
storm
who made her comic debut in 1975's giant
size
x-men number one in joining the avengers
monica continued a proud history and
blazed a trail into the future
throughout the years
a plethora of marvel superheroes have
led the avengers ranging from popular
characters like luke cage
to lesser known types like dr druid
carol danvers then working as ms marvel
has actually led the team before herself
but as it turns out she isn't the only
captain marvel to earn that particular
distinction
captain america actually nominates
monica rambo
then still known as captain marvel for
the team's leadership role in 1987's
avengers number 279
after then leader wasp decides to step
down during her time in charge
rambo's avengers battle greek gods as
well as ames cosmic
cuban-powered nightmare robot super
adaptoid
although being in charge certainly suits
her monika's reign as the leader of the
avengers comes to an abrupt
end about a year after her inauguration
after a debilitating accident drains her
powers and nearly kills her
dr druid takes over after she resigns
and
let's just say doesn't do such a great
job
marvel has chosen some pretty strange
characters to put into the spotlight
over the years
ever heard of maverick an energy
absorbing mutant who
like wolverine went through the weapon x
program probably not
but he got his own 12 issue comic run in
1997.
what about warlock the shape-shifting
alien and x-men affiliate
who got his own nine issue run in 1999
no
well perhaps you're familiar with the
craptacular b-sides
a gang of new jersey teenagers with
powers like owning
an actually magical magic 8-ball no
well they too got their own solo series
back in 2002
and craptacular is right there in their
name given how unheard of most of these
characters are
it's surprising to the casual fan that
they've ever been given their own comic
it's even more shocking when you
consider the fact that monica rambo who
leads the freaking avengers at one point
has never been given her own solo series
sure
she had a pair of one-shot issues as
captain marvel one in 1989 and one in
1994
but never her own multi-issue run this
is a snub
of epic proportions considering monica's
major significance in the marvel
universe throughout the years
superheroes tend to go through a lot of
names over the years
sometimes it's to disguise their
identity as when hawkeye
reborn after the events of the house of
m storyline decides to go by ronin
sometimes it's to take up the mantle of
another hero's legacy
as when the mutant assassin psylocke
takes on the captain britain name after
her brother retires from the role
and then sometimes your monika rambo and
all
bets are absolutely off the one-time
captain marvel has changed her vigilante
alias more times than most fans can keep
track of
it begins when she gives the captain
marvel title to mar-vell's son
janice val in honor of his father's
legacy and chooses to become
photon instead however this isn't the
only time that genus makes things
difficult for poor monica
as he later starts going by photon too
instead of fighting him for the name
rambo simply changes hers to pulsar
although she goes by the name of pulsar
for a while
monica eventually settles on the name of
spectrum as spectrum
monica plays an important role on luke
cage's mighty avengers team
at one point even going to toe with the
powerful child of thanos
proxima midnight fingers crossed that
spectrum sticks
because her costume is undeniably cool
and
honestly doesn't monica deserve a little
stability in her life
monica rambo's time as photon is
relatively uneventful
with one very important exception in the
pages of next wave
agents of hate a hilariously self-aware
over-the-top comic series written by
warren
ellis in which monica gets to be wild
weird
and wonderful not to mention she acts as
the leader of the agents of hate
an acronym for highest anti-terrorism
effort adding yet another entry onto her
long list of accomplishments
joining monica is an assortment of minor
marvel characters
including x-force's tabitha smith the
monster hunting elsa bloodstone
machine man and a foul-mouthed newbie
who simply goes by
the captain the book is very much a
parody of a marvel comic
with hate being an obvious play on
shield
because of this it shows off a rarely
seen funny side of rambo who is right at
home leading a gang of marvelous misfits
in the sprawling world of comic books
determining the most powerful marvel
superhero
is a complicated task thor and hulk are
pretty popular choices
but some would argue villainous
candidates like galactus
and apocalypse are actually stronger
while she might not be the first name
that comes to mind
monica rambo is a contender as well her
energy-based powers don't just make her
a formidable force to be reckoned with
they might also make her immortal in
2019's avengers
no road home monica now spectrum has a
deeply philosophical discussion with
vision about the inevitability of human
death
rambo is quick to point out that her
body is actually a vessel of pure energy
so technically she cannot die does this
make her less human
she and vision come to agree that only
they can determine the answer for
themselves
what is clear however is the extent of
monica's abilities
she could live for decades even
centuries protected from battle
old age and general wear and tear
even the most powerful superheroes have
a weakness superman's notorious achilles
heel
is kryptonite luke cage's impenetrable
skin is susceptible to adamantium
and wolverine's healing abilities are
rendered ineffective when the injury is
dealt with by the muramasa blade
it's a long story although she might be
vastly powerful
even monica rambo winds up on death's
doorstep every once in a while
in 1988's avengers number 293 and number
294
namor the submariner's wife marina
smallwood
transforms into a gigantic sea monster
leaving the avengers to hunt her down
when they find her monica turns herself
into a bolt of electricity
in order to stop the deadly creature
unfortunately when she contacts the
water
she accidentally conducts herself across
the entire ocean
when her fellow avengers find her she is
shrunken and near lifeless
although she lives through the traumatic
experience she temporarily loses her
powers
leaving her no option but to quit the
superhero game and resign from the
avengers
monika eventually regains her abilities
but not until after a long time spent
being haunted by the painful way she
nearly lost her life
water and electricity certainly don't
mix especially when you're an energy
based superhero
superheroes hooking up with other
superheroes is as much a part of the
genre as the origin story
luke cage loves jessica jones kitty
prides has a history with colossus and
rogan gambit have
actually managed to get married likewise
monica rambo has shared intimate moments
with a couple of supermen throughout the
years
2009's limited series marvel divas
features monica teaming up with fellow
gal pals
hellcat firestar and black cat
here it is revealed that while helping
clean up after hurricane katrina
monica and jericho drum the sorcerer
better known as brother voodoo
made a connection and acted on it
however
the one-time sorcerer supreme isn't
monica's only love interest
during 2013's run of mighty avengers
monika
now using the name spectrum gets injured
fighting proxima midnight
and has to be healed by fellow avenger
adam brashear
aka blue marvel this leads to a very
strong relationship
and one heck of a power couple blue
marvel's powers include cosmic
intelligence
anti-matter manipulation and energy
control
although she makes her debut as a kid in
captain marvel monica rambo's part in
the colossal
mcu is set to extend far beyond her
childhood her next appearance will come
in the upcoming disney plus series
one division with mad men's tiana paris
cast as a grown-up version of the
character
wanda what's up who are you
i don't know if you're confused by how
monica's inclusion will make sense in
this series you're not alone
heck everything about wandavision is
still shrouded in mystery
including the very premise of how vision
who is presumably destroyed by thanos in
avengers infinity war
comes back from the dead marvel's promos
for the show
only introduced more questions
showcasing various scenes of paul
bettany's vision
and elizabeth olsen's scarlet witch from
seemingly different time periods
throw monica rambo into the mix and
you've got one serious head scratcher
this is gonna be a gas leaked set photos
of paris's rambo wearing a blue sword
jacket
seemingly confirmed that she will be
working for or
with the space-based task force which
has yet to make an appearance
in the mcu fans will just have to wait
and see how it all comes together
when wanda vision hits disney plus check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]